I'm Cory Rosen and I'm the director of
the National Center for employee
ownership we are a private nonprofit
membership based information
organization located in Oakland and our
purpose in life is to provide objective
reliable information about broad-based
employee ownership plans we're not about
trying to help executives get more
wealth although I do want to say that I
have after a great deal of reflection
and thought found a solution to the
problem of excessive executive
compensation even Business Week now
worries that executives are taking home
too much pay 500 times the average pay
of an employee in large companies and so
what it occurred to me is that since
nobody actually can spend that much
money in a lifetime or their kids
lifetime or small nation's lifetime that
what we might do instead if in fact this
is not about being able to consume the
hundreds of millions of dollars but
rather to be ranked as the highest paid
executive is that we reduce their pay to
say 50 times what the average worker
would make take the other four hundred
and fifty times and hire professional
agitators and these would be people who
would sing the praises of the CEO they
would be dramatist and artists and
musicians and sculptors and we would
have these magnificent edifices our
grandchildren and their grandchildren
could visit just as we go visit the
grand palaces and museums that were
built to adulate the great princes of a
time passed we would abolish the NEA
because there'd be so much work for
these artists now and of course
employees would be a lot more motivated
because these agitators would make it
clear to the employees just how truly
exceptional these CEOs work and I have
to say that although we even got this
published in the San Francisco Chronicle
I've yet to receive a call from any
these companies saying they'd like to
implement this proposal so giving up on
the idea of solving excess excessive
executive pay we focused instead on the
idea of trying to find ways to broaden
ownership beyond just the top few in
society today about 1% of the population
owns more than 50% of the privately held
productive capital if you filled up the
football stadium over here with the
richest people in America those families
would own more than the gross national
product of over half the countries in
the world
now that concentration of wealth is on
the one hand something that a lot of
economists say well so what who cares
don't worry about it that's just the way
it is if people can know that they can
get that rich it's a motivation for them
to go out and accumulate more money and
to build businesses and to take risks
and that's what capitalism is all about
and we shouldn't worry about what this
disparity is as long as the total levels
of capital are high and indeed we've
preached that message aggressively
around the world but we're beginning to
see that that's causing some problems
and indeed again even the more
conservative business publications are
starting to worry that maybe this
excessive disparity in wealth
accumulation not just in our countries
but in a lot of the market countries
that are moving towards capitalism
undermine support for the basic system
if people think it's essentially unfair
then when people can vote after all with
their feet or at the ballot box and it's
one person each not one dollar each you
may get a very different result from
what the market would preach now back in
the 1950s an economist and investment
banker in San Francisco lawyer Louis
Kelso was thinking about this problem
long before too many other people were
thinking about it other than Marxists
who were thinking
about in a very different way Kelso was
by no means a Marxist in fact he thought
Marxism was a pretty stupid idea but he
also looked at what he thought was going
to happen
over the next 50 years or so and he said
we're gonna have more capital investment
in the next generation then all of the
generations that have preceded it
combined we're going to have more
technological change in the next
generation then all the generations that
have preceded it combined and what's
going to happen is that a lot of the
jobs that now provide people with
relatively good pay that relatively low
skills if you're willing to work hard
are going to be replaced by capital and
technology and the jobs that get created
are going to be increasingly service
sector jobs that don't pay very well now
in the 1950s people didn't envision that
globalization would play the role that
it does but now even jobs that might
otherwise pay well because they are
fairly high skilled jobs are being
exported abroad to places with lower
labor costs so what's happening is as
Kelso predicted that there'd be downward
pressure on wages while at the same time
investment in capital would show soaring
returns from 1973 through 2003 the
median adjusted income in the United
States for inflation the median income
went out point three percent per year
but during that same period of time the
Dow Jones average went from having three
digits to five so if you were invested
in capital growth you did quite well and
if you weren't you didn't do very well
at all now Kelso said the problem that
we're gonna see is that people are gonna
say this is not fair I can't make ends
meet I have trouble sending my kids to
school I have trouble paying for health
insurance
have trouble supporting my retirement
government do something for me and the
government would respond that when the
government responded it would take money
out of the economy then I would slow the
economy down so you'd have this
inevitable tension between policies
designed to create more fairness more
equity in the economy and policies
designed to create more growth and I
think if you look now what's going on
between conservatives liberals Democrats
Republicans that's a pretty fair way to
characterize that divide so Kelso said
the answer obviously is somehow for
employees to get a piece of that capital
ownership now the traditional approach
is that if people want to become owners
what do they do they save their money
and they buy stock
well great idea except if wages are
stagnant but consumer needs keep going
up because consumer needs always keep
going up we need bigger houses we need
bigger cars we need cable television we
need cell phones we need computers we
need all these things that we didn't
need in the 1950s and we were quite
happy without them so all these costs go
up but our wages don't go up and so we
don't have the money to save and indeed
savings rates are now negative so that's
not gonna work what else can you do well
you can have special talents you can be
a Bill Gates you can go to Stanford
Business School and you can be an
entrepreneur and you can build a
business and that's great but it's a
very small percentage of the population
that's going to have that kind of
ability now of course the best choice to
make is choose your parents wisely now a
lot of people here for instance maybe
did make that choice a lot of people
didn't but overall in the population
most people make a terrible choice so if
none of those work then what are you
gonna do
and Kelso's solution was somehow the
workplace needs to transfer ownership to
employees and the mechanism he created
was something called an employee stock
ownership plan or ISA and that was the
first effort to create this ownership
plan that would be for all the employees
not just for a few and I won't go into
all the gory details of how this works
but essentially what an esop is is an
arrangement in which a trust fund for
employees can borrow money to buy shares
in the company and the company pays back
the loan so the employees don't buy the
stock the company buys the stock for
them and there are a variety of tax
benefits to the employer for being
willing to do that while the employee
doesn't actually have to put up any of
the employees own money and in fact in
1998 Congress did something that I still
rub my eyes about I've been doing this
since the late 1970s in fact used to
work on Capitol Hill and was working on
drafting some of this legislation and my
friends and I we get together and we'd
say well everywhere in the world what
would it be like and we'd say well we
would say that a business that was a
hundred percent owned by its employees
that paid no federal income tax then we
laugh because there's just a totally
ridiculous idea and today that's the law
1998 Congress said that's great
so all these tax benefits to encourage
companies to do that why you might ask
would Congress ever do such a thing it
sounds like some sort of utopian vision
straight out of our friend Karl Marx
well in fact employee ownership is the
one thing that all three jessee's have
come to agree on Helms Jackson and
Ventura for the Republicans this is
really cool
you mean we're going to create lots of
people who own stock we know what people
who own stock do they vote Republican we
love more capitalists and the Democrats
say this is great we've been looking for
a way somehow to create a more equitable
distribution of wealth we're not getting
it done through the government we're not
getting it done through taxation
here's the way we can use the enterprise
system itself to do it so these employee
stock ownership plans started to get
established in the 1970s and today they
are about ten thousand plans covering
eleven million employees some of these
companies are very large companies like
public supermarkets for instance with a
hundred and twenty five thousand
employees is entirely owned by its
employees and has been for a long time
and consistently rates not just as the
top consumer approved supermarket chain
in the United States but often is
considered the best for customer service
of any kind of company in the United
States that Wall Street Journal used to
publish this every year science
applications a company in Southern
California 42,000 employees in the late
1960s Bob Meister who started the
company thought that gee no it's not
really fair for me even though I started
this company it's not really fair for me
to own all the stock and in fact I think
if I could get other people to be owners
in this company they'd have the same
motivation I do and they'd help this
company to grow so within the first year
he owned less than ten percent of the
stock is he giving away the rest of it
to his employees when he retired a few
years ago he owned less than 2% of the
stock but the company wasn't a company
of a handful of people
it had 42,000 employees it was worth
billions and billions of dollars and he
ended up just where he thought he would
with a smaller piece of a much much
bigger pie part of that through an
employee ownership plan and I just
described part of it through other
mechanisms of employee ownership I'll
talk about in a minute most of these
companies though are closely held
companies with twenty to a hundred to a
thousand employees they're the
manufacturing company out in the
industrial park they're the engineering
and consulting company in the office
park there every day companies
closely-held where the owner of the
company
typically is thinking about retiring or
maybe it's multiple owners and one of
them is thinking about it and they'd
like to get part are all of their
ownership sold in a way that a is tax
advantaged and B keeps the identity of
the business going that this business
that they work so hard to build doesn't
just get sold to somebody else and the
people who worked with them and helped
build it they may not have a job
identity a company is lost and so this
becomes a very attractive mechanism for
providing for business continuity now as
these Aesop's grew through the 80s and
90s research started to be done on how's
this doing there's this worth of public
investment turns out it's actually not
very expensive in terms of tax benefits
but still there's maybe one and a half
two billion dollars in tax costs going
to this and these days that's not much
money this Bob Dole said back in the
1980s a billion here a billion there
you're starting to talk about money so
we're just starting to talk about money
on that well it turns out there's been a
huge amount of research done we talked a
lot about it in this book we published
through Harvard and what that research
shows is that in general employee on
employee stock ownership plan companies
grow about two to three percent per year
faster then you would have expected them
to grow if they didn't have a plan what
we did in this research as we said let's
look at how these companies were doing
relative to their competition let's say
they were here and their competition was
here so they were good companies but
then they set up their ESOP and they
moved up here so what we're looking at
is this difference and that difference
was about two to three percent per year
faster when we looked a little deeper we
said well probably some companies doing
better than others and we found that
when we looked at all kinds of things we
looked at unionization size industry
demographics where your employees more
educated where they higher paid
more senior all kinds of things that you
might think would affect this none of
them did
none of them were related except for
three things one was how much ownership
employees were getting each year
symbolic ownership doesn't get you very
far
the second was how effectively the
company communicated that the company
was employee owned but the most
important was how participated the
company was in the way it was managed
did they have teams did they share
financial information that the good
employees involved in day to day
decisions and those companies were
growing about 8 to 11 percent per year
faster was the company is a very
top-down management we're actually
growing more slowly so people have said
well gee Cory what you found was it's
important to give people a sense of
ownership at work an ability to have
more control over the job that they do
and yeah that's true they said well if
that's the case and what do you need to
actually share ownership with people for
x-pensive and you don't have to give
that up it's yours well it turns out
that companies that do that and
certainly there are a lot of companies
that do it if you go back to the 80s we
had quality circles they only had total
quality management then we had
re-engineering then we had matrix
management we had learning companies I'm
not sure where we are today but each one
is about 3 years and then it disappears
because employees say it's just a fad
and it will pass you can wait it out
because there really isn't anything in
that for them and what it turns out is
that with the employee ownership plan
participation programs persist and grow
because employees look at that and say
there's something there at the end of
the day for me it's not what motivates
me what motivates me is the content of
the work and the way we organize work
but if I'm going to do this I'd better
get something out of it so we say that
if for instance we wanted to give people
a sense of ownership that we'd like to
take those management consultants to
dinner with us
and we'd have a nice banquet in a very
atmospheric place and we'd let them soak
up the atmosphere and smell the food and
fact we'd even help them wash the dishes
afterwards but we would only give them a
sense of dinner well a sense of
ownership turns out to be about as
effective as a sense of dinner if
anything it's manipulative and people
don't like it look at the job
satisfaction scores today and how dismal
e low job satisfaction scores are in the
United States they continued to fall
people continue to feel that the
disparity and pay between them and
higher levels of the company the lack of
respect and dignity they have at work
are things that really make their work
experience not what they hoped it would
be
so as these Aesop's became established a
respectable part of American business in
the 1980s another trend developed and
that was technology companies who like
SAIC when they were founded they were
founded by people who in large measure
are pretty frustrated that the companies
they had worked for and that they had
developed ideas for didn't give them
ownership of the company and they said
well when we start a company it's going
to be different we're gonna share
ownership with more people and maybe at
first that was just that programmers and
the software engineers or the developers
of products or whatever because they
thought well these are the key people
but pretty quickly they realize who's
not a key person here if somebody calls
the company and they get really rotten
service now I called MCI spent 30 hours
on the phone a few weeks ago trying to
get my 92 year old mother's phone
service restored MCI may have a
brilliant strategy now that they've come
out of bankruptcy and their brilliant
strategy isn't to pretend how much money
they're making they may have great
technology but it doesn't
matter because I spent 30 hours trying
to get my mother's phone service
restored and so did my sister and
finally somebody said to my sister a
third-level manager there you know what
if I had a 92 year old mother I wouldn't
use MCI now they may have terrific
management but the company to the
customer is the person who answered the
phone so companies started to figure out
everybody here makes a contribution so
these technology company starts
spreading ownership more broadly amongst
the early pioneers or companies like
Intel and Cisco and Microsoft well this
created a problem for the companies who
didn't like that idea well we don't want
to share ownership if everyone this is
our idea we'll give it to some people
not gonna give it to everybody of course
that made it kind of difficult to get
good employees when they could go to one
of these other big rapidly growing
companies and they were given ownership
to everybody so whether you want it to
do it or didn't want to do it he kind of
hadn't do it and so by the middle of the
nineties virtually every technology
company was giving stock options the
right to buy shares at a price fixed
today for a defined number of years into
the future to just about everybody and
that continues to this day despite
discussions about changes in accounting
rules making companies pull back on that
now as that started to happen some other
companies started to take a look at this
and say you know if it's a good idea for
them maybe it's a good idea for us to
people think of us we're a small chain
of coffee stores in the 1980s people
think of us it's not a very high-tech
place you know coffee shops you grind
the coffee you pour it into the cup you
give it to the customer and a story well
Howard Schultz at Starbucks had a
different idea he said we'd actually
like these people to stick around for a
while
turnover in our industries 300 percent a
year we spent a lot of time training
these people and we have a much more
varied and complex product than the
traditional coffee shop we'd like these
people
they actually have some ideas of their
own about ways that they can develop
this product better or serve the
customers better we want to know what
these people think we'd also like to
know what they're hearing from customers
so if we want to reduce training costs
who want to increase the flow of ideas
we want to increase the amount of
information we're getting how can we
motivate people actually after all don't
make all that much money typically but
we can give them healthcare benefits for
everybody we can give them stock options
for everybody and meaningful amounts of
stock options so that's what they
decided to do back in the late 1980s
when they went public their investment
bankers said you're out of your mind
why on earth what an investor want to
invest in a company that's crazy enough
to give away equity to people pouring
coffee and so they called us is there
any research that shows this actually
works and I said yes as a matter of fact
there is and so their investment bankers
decided reluctantly to live with it
and that's turned out to be a reasonably
good investment since 1987 I'm not sure
where it ranks but I would guess it
ranks in the top 10 and their turnover
now is 60% the industry's still 300
percent other companies started looking
at that to companies like Whole Foods
for instance they said you know we're
gonna manage this company a completely
different way than anybody's managed a
supermarket before rather than having
every store be exactly alike with the
same customer policies and the same
products on its shelves in the same look
of the store we're gonna organize all
these employees into teams there's a
grocery team and there's a cheese team
and there's that whatever you know you
go to any store there's a team member
from so on come here well all these
employees are organized into teams the
teams will have some same how the stores
laid out and remodeled and even the
product mix that goes there based on the
what they hear from their local
customers about what they're interested
in have
the teams also meet to set goals for
themselves they're given all the
information they need about how the
company makes money and they're said
okay what do we do on the grocery team
to help this company generate more
profits well for us the critical thing
is shrinkage I don't know what it is but
it might well be shrinkage so let's have
a goal of reducing shrinkage by X
percent and if we meet this goal this is
the reward we'd like and they set their
own goals and I set their own awards
with the only constraint big enough to
publish them so everybody else knows
what they're doing the teams each team
elects someone to a store team so the
store wide team from each of the teams
store team has somebody going to the
next layer or whatever it is regional
divisional all the way up to the
corporate national office so there's all
these ideas that are constantly flowing
back and forth all this information
coming up from the bottom as well as
going down to the top how important is
that in any large organization even a
small organization robert rice just
wrote a really interesting article about
the bush administration i don't mean
this is a political comment but purely
as an organizational one and his
observation was that the bush
administration is terrific at getting
elected because their very own message
everybody has the same message loyalty
is the highest virtue and that's great
for winning elections but it's a real
problem for governing because when you
appoint people and promote people based
on loyalty and everybody being on the
same message how do you get the
information that's discordant how do you
get the information that gee that idea
maybe didn't work that maybe the message
we have on this particular issue isn't
the right one we should try something
else you don't and what happens is
information starts going up these
hierarchies and you don't tell your boss
you're a bozo you only say that was a
bad idea
they say well
you think is a bad idea you sort of
gloss it over and then it goes up
another level like it's gloss tool and
it gets glossed a little more and by the
time it gets the top it was a great idea
in the 80s when I was starting the
center I worked for a company called
control dated they don't exist anymore
and in our office in Washington we had
to come up with a report each year based
on what we thought was going to happen
and nobody wanted to tell the boss that
what we thought was going to happen in
the particular area that we were working
on was that the boss's idea was gonna
work so you because he wanted to not be
look too stupid so you tried to sort of
make it sort of look like it would work
and sort of look like it wouldn't well
by the time we got back what what they
had heard at the top from what we had
said things look great and the company's
projections every year were growing and
growing and growing until it's what
turned out not to be so brilliant market
idea that pcs would never go anywhere
that the real money in computer was
these remote servers that people would
have links to I forgot not even what
that was called but needless to say its
history and the company's history so
it's real hard to get that information
there so companies like Whole Foods are
saying there's got to be a different way
again we're talking about big companies
but the same dynamic would apply in a
company with two employees where one's
the boss and one's not you have to have
that kind of trust and openness between
people so that you can really get the
information you need to make intelligent
decisions and people have to be
motivated enough so that they'll tell
you in the first place so these ideas
came to fruition in the mid-90s in a
number of companies and we ended up with
about 10 million employees getting stock
options through companies that were
sharing them with most or all employees
and these companies too were
outperforming expectation productivity
rates went up about 17 percent in the
three-year period post adoption over
what you would have expected if they
didn't
have these kinds of plans now there's
some pullback from that now because
changes in accounting rules and
shoulders getting that about dilution
and so some companies are saying do we
really need to do this if we can't give
out as many options as we used to
well we better give them mostly to our
quote unquote key people because they're
the ones who really make the difference
now of course the stock market has a
different reaction because turns out
that when companies announce that
they're giving grants to most of their
employees stock prices go up and when
they announce they're gonna increase the
grants that are already going to CEOs
stock prices go down but again it's
maybe that information disconnected when
you're the CEO when you're the
compensation consultant to the CEO when
you're the board of directors made up of
other CEOs it's real hard to say no you
know maybe you're not right about that
maybe this model that we have that if
everybody else at the 50% level of
compensation we should be at the 50%
level for CEOs not for everybody else by
the way but we should be at this 50%
level at least or maybe the 75% level
for our top officers and that's why
that's a good reason to do that and
that's how a lot of compensation set so
if everybody else is increasing options
or other kinds of equity awards which
was what they're doing now then we
should - it's a curious analytical tool
isn't it can you imagine the product
acquisition manager who goes to the
board or to a CEO and says well I
figured out we should buy this twenty
million dollar new computer system and
the way I figured it out is that fifty
percent of the rest of our competitors
have it and so if everybody else or at
least half the people have it must be a
good idea so who must work for us - well
you get fired
for something that dumb but if you say
our compensation should be done because
that's what everybody else is doing
that's fine so the result of all this is
some pullback but not a lot we might see
a 20 percent pullback
but in the long run I think you're gonna
see this continue to grow and that's
because the nature of business itself
has changed it used to be that a
business could make a lot of money doing
the same thing the same way over and
over again any business whether it was
selling coffee or selling hamburgers or
making jeans or making computer chips
for a long time it was efficiency that
drove a corporate a corporation's
profits and so if you could find ways to
do that same thing just a little more
efficiently each time that was a good
system and hierarchies were well adapted
to that because they set up routines so
that everybody did this exactly the same
way day after day after day well the
world's changed now the emphasis more on
companies is on effectiveness that's a
distinction I think a brilliant one that
Peter Drucker has made between doing the
right thing and doing the thing right
the emphasis now is more on doing the
right thing there are a number of
reasons for that one is that the
diversity of products and services has
changed immensely from what it used to
be it used to be that companies could
offer two or three or four products and
pretty much the same thing over and over
again now companies have many many more
products than many many more services
when I was growing up and my mother took
me to the athletic store I could get
athletic shoes high top low top black or
white those are my choices now if I want
to go get a pair of running shoes I go
to a running shoe store and they asked
me do i supinate or pronate run on fail
off trail how much do I weigh how much
do I run each week and then there are 12
shoes for me to choose from services are
equally diverse so now companies have
this much larger number of things they
have to deal with on that dimension but
not only is there more
product and service diversity but the
speed with which things are changing is
a great deal faster the lifecycle of
these products and services much shorter
if you do something well somebody else
going to copy whatever you do very
quickly so new strategic ideas have a
very short lifespan of competitive
advantage you not only have to do the
new thing well but you have to figure
out the next new thing before your
competitor does and the next new thing
and the next new thing and that's
multiplied remember by this much wider
variety of products and services the
third thing that's changed is there's a
lot more information
the bank teller today on the screen has
more information the bank CEO had 15
years ago that bank teller is an
enormous amount of information about
what that customer has done and if that
bank teller couldn't look at that
history and say gene looking at your
banking history I see that this would
actually be a better product for you how
much does that improve that customers
relationship with the company and maybe
sell that customer on products and
services that would never happen unless
that bank teller had that information
how the training had the motivation to
do something about it so much more
information now return to that old
hierarchical model where information is
moving up and up and up and decisions go
down and down and down takes a long time
the information gets distorted as
decisions get pushed up the more
decisions there are the fewer get made
it's not enough time to do all this it's
not an efficient model so instead you
have to disaggregate decision making now
you've got a lot of people making a lot
of decisions about a lot more things
more quickly and if they're not simply
going to make more decisions about more
things more quickly badly they need
business information they need to know
how's the company make money was our
income statement look like what are the
numbers the drive performance in this
particular unit and everybody needs to
know them because
everybody's involved in these decisions
they need a reason to care ownership is
a great reason to care but above all
they need a structure to do it in most
companies say we're an open open to our
company people are our most important
asset but nobody walks through the open
door because it's too ambiguous the
management doesn't really fully believe
that they're their most important asset
anyway and so yeah we want you to share
ideas and information gets translated
into if you feel like it whereas the
really effective companies say you have
to share ideas information because it's
part of your job it's part of what we
expect from you and so we're gonna
organize you into teams or
cross-functional teams or work teams or
self managing teams or whatever kind of
team we can think of that we're gonna
say here's your responsibility you
manage us you do it you figure out how
to make money doing it so as we've moved
to that system that system where people
are really thinking and acting like
business people where people's ideas and
information are tried the primary asset
of corporations and today over
two-thirds of the value of publicly
traded stock his consists of intangible
assets the intellectual capital that
come that employees are contributing
then who really owns these companies
what does ownership of the company mean
any more financial ownership does it
mean who owns the bricks-and-mortar
the real assets are intellectual capital
the ideas and information that people
are contributing then the owners of
those ideas and information are the
employees and they can take that capital
and move it someplace else very easily
it's very liquid capital so if those are
the real owners shouldn't they be the
actual owners as well
I only just conclude with an example of
how I think a company has done this in
its most fully developed form it's
company called WL Gore so
you may not recognize the company but
you no doubt recognize the product
gore-tex when WL Gore Associates was
created Bill Gore thought that they
should run things a whole lot
differently than they did before he
didn't like working at DuPont even feel
that that he was really treated that
well he'd come up with this product idea
that later became Teflon and he didn't
really feel like he got the right kind
of ownership of that they form his own
company and they were fooling around
with Teflon and it's one of those great
stories of you know down in the basement
we made a mistake and lo and behold we
found that this plastic stuff that we
had was not water permeable but it
breathed well boy we can do a lot of
stuff with that
so gore associates said well we're gonna
do things a whole lot differently first
of all we're gonna be an employee-owned
company in fact we're not to have
employees all you have associates
secondly we don't think that expertise
that authority should be consistent with
position we think authority should be
consistent with expertise and expertise
on any particular issues going to shift
third we want people to take
responsibility for their own work and
not constantly have to check with us we
want entrepreneurs at this company so
they said we're not going to build any
facility bigger than about a hundred and
fifty because we want everybody to know
one another because if they don't know
one another you're gonna end up with
hierarchy and bureaucracy secondly we're
not going to have any management
structure no titles no reporting system
when you're hired here you won't be
hired for a job you'll be assigned a
mentor who helps figure out what it is
that you might actually contribute to
the company your pay will be based
largely on a 360 review and you'll have
a pay champion appear to help argue your
case for how much you should be paid
when a project comes up who will come up
because somebody has an idea gee you
know we could use this gore-tex on
dental floor
and it would be a really neat product
well you don't have to go get
management's approval because there
isn't really any management because
there's no titles there's no hierarchy
what you do have to do is go convince
enough of your colleagues to join a team
with you and see if you can actually do
this and if you can and you can do it
and that's a really tough hurdle because
you've got to convince a lot of people
to stop doing what they are doing and
join you and do that instead
now those teams will sort of not elect
but the leaders emerge from this so that
you might be a leader on this project
but not on another and indeed 50% of the
associates that Gore say that they are
leaders and this is now a company of
about 7,000 employees that is
consistently named one of the best
companies in America to work for they
were they've been named the best company
in England to work for for the past few
years running they've grown a 20% of
year sales and profits for about 20
years and they've done this with the
system that everybody else looks totally
chaotic but if you ask them what makes
it work they say it's not chaotic at all
it's the most disciplined demanding
system you can imagine because nothing
gets done here unless you can make an
extremely good case to a lot of
committed people that this is what we
should do but then if you can do it boy
go and do it and nobody's gonna get in
your way so it's become an
extraordinarily innovative company an
extraordinarily effective company and
apparently an extraordinarily good place
to work the last thing I'll say is that
all this stuff is great these companies
make more money the employees stay
longer employees generate it turns out a
great deal more financial assets through
these plans than they would through
conventional retirement and benefit
plans three times as much in Aesop's for
instance but at the end of the day when
you talk to a lot of the owners of these
businesses and you say what really is
satisfying about this they
saying all that stuff you just said is
great I love the tax breaks I love the
productivity I love the performance but
it was the right thing to do what really
makes me feel good as I did the right
thing I remember listening to somebody
talk at a conference about 20 years ago
and he said when you live your life you
want to think about what do you want to
be remembered for and very few people
say I don't want to be I want to be
remembered because I was really rich I
want to be remembered because people say
boy that was a good-looking guy he had a
big car he had a huge house people will
want to remember you because what did I
do for my community what did I do for my
fellow man and woman what did I do for
my family and that sense of satisfaction
is so much deeper and so much more
important than anything else that you
can achieve that if it worked you can
say I did the right thing I provided an
atmosphere that gave people dignity and
respect that there's nothing better than
that so if you go off and you create
your own businesses I hope you'll keep
that thought in mind because it's it's
the best reward that you could possibly
have so questions comments I'd be happy
to talk about some of the technical
specific stuff about all this - yeah yes
in in companies that have employee
ownership plans are about as unionized
as companies that aren't which isn't
very unionized anymore and some unions
look at this and they say we don't want
to be management it's a terrible idea
other unions have embraced it where you
have very adversarial labor-management
relationships the presence of a union
and employee ownership doesn't mix very
well because you can't get to that kind
of cooperative high involvement model
where the union management
ship is more positive then it builds on
itself and it's just another way to
encourage it and the best example of
this is in the airline industry
Southwest Airlines is almost entirely
unionized most unionized carrier in the
industry a lot of people assume that
it's not unionized at all that's not
true and they've had an employee
ownership plan almost since the outset
when they as everybody I think who's
followed them knows they'd been an
extraordinarily successful example of
creating a different kind of workplace
that has allowed them to thrive and at
least now survive in a market where
since deregulation 198 carriers have
gone bankrupt so far United Airlines of
course famously had an employee
ownership plan but that very adversarial
relationship between management and
labor and they did all these things I
was talking about in the first year and
they did great
as a result they have all kinds of cost
savings people were enthused the end of
the first year they hired a new vice
president for people as they called it
at the time they got a new CEO and the
new CEO and the new vice president
people didn't like the idea of employee
ownership they weren't comfortable with
it the union leaders never were really
comfortable with it even though it been
their idea they didn't like the idea of
all this cooperation with management and
as soon as they could get back to the
old ways of banging on one another's
heads they did and they were much
happier that way for a short time and
then everything imploded and they did
basically everything you could do wrong
with the employee ownership they did one
of each yeah I mean
right right right yeah they do a lot of
things right at Southwest right right it
would be wrong and naive to say that the
only reason that Southwest has succeeded
is because of its employee culture but
if it's it's a big big difference a
friend of mine once said that Southwest
Airlines the only airline that can treat
you like cattle and make you like it and
it's because employees there have a very
different attitude than they do at the
all of the legacy carriers yeah
right well yes
good question right right very good
question there a number of ways
companies traditionally look at that the
startup companies they'll say okay we're
gonna give ownership to each new
employee in the company and you'll have
some cutoff criteria at the bottom maybe
will you have to work here for a year or
you have to get to you know if you're a
Windies that when they had everybody had
options I'd say you have to become an
assistant manager well that's not a very
big hurdle in that kind of store but
there'd be some basic hurdle you'd have
to cross that would show that you had
some real commitment to the company you
weren't just sort of visiting and the
second thing they need to think about is
what mechanism do we use to share
ownership now if you're a startup
company and aesop's not the mechanism
you're going to use it's too cumbersome
too expensive lots of tax benefits but
you don't need any tax benefits so you
know look at something more like an
individual equity arrangement it could
be a stock option phantom stock which
essentially says they're not going to
give you real shares but the cash
equivalent of share value stock
appreciation rights which say we're
going to give you the value of the
increase in the company there are
different mechanisms restricted stock is
another approach but all of these are
mechanisms that say you individually
gonna have a piece of the equity value
of the company and you have to look at
the different tax issues and that's kind
of a mechanical assessment of what's
going to work given the demographics of
your company the third thing you have to
look at is how much ownership do we give
away and that's a much trickier issue
traditionally what we hear from startup
companies is somebody'll call and say
well I'm comfortable with 10% of the
ownership that that seems okay with me
if you have venture capital investment
they may say we're comfortable with this
level and they'll want you to share
ownership with other employees they may
even require it and
and they may have their own thoughts
about what that level should be there's
some given them intuitively that makes
sense and say here's the level I'm
comfortable with but it runs into some
real problems over time the first is
let's say you say 10% but I want to give
it all the way right away because what
if we get a little bigger in it you know
then I've got the next person and I've
already given away nine percent so you
say well maybe I'll give away five
percent and then you get bigger than you
thought you would so now you you right
you've got this five is 10 percent
ceiling you're bigger than you were
you're hiring people maybe even higher
levels than you were and you're saying
I'm sorry I can only give you a thousand
options although our person who actually
is now below you is getting two thousand
options which by the way are more
valuable because they were granted at a
lower price but you say I can't give
away more than ten percent so I'm kind
of stuck so there's an alternative way
to look at this and this is we'll call
it the beyster model and the visor model
said it's not important what percentage
of the company I own it's important how
much the value of that company that I
own is so if you say okay to the group
of six people who join you to begin with
here's our target for the year if we
meet this target then I'm comfortable of
giving you X percent of that target 25
percent let's say and pick some number
that you're comfortable with 25 percent
of that target in the form of equity in
the company because when you know if
you're at this level of sophistication
you figured something out if your target
is say profitability and you increase
your profitability by a hundred thousand
dollars over your target and you have a
price earnings ratio of 10 to one so if
you give away 25 percent of that
you keep the 75% and that's worth
750,000 dollars in equity follow I'm
saying because the price earnings ratio
is 10 to 1 and you've created another
75,000 in earnings you've given away 25%
of it but G have ended up with a whole
lot more than what you started with so
now you're at this new level and you get
some warrant you have to hire some more
people well you can do the same deal
with them if we get to this level then
here's the deal for you
now when you try to figure out how much
should that be you need to pay some
attention to what people expect they're
going to get in terms of what the
competitive labor market is and I don't
think you should simply say let's go for
the median and there are lots of surveys
you can in there useful information but
every company is different every
compensation package has different
elements there are different rewards to
working for different companies that
aren't compensation related so use that
just as a sort of general idea you need
to be in that ballpark but you don't
need to be right at the 50 percent
median either and so that helps you
figure out how much of this increment do
we give away new boy if we do a lot
better than this increment you'll do
even better than that median everybody
thinks so I can help you get to better
than average so they're you know they're
gonna see that as a pretty good deal and
you can just keep doing this dad
infinitum the other thing that that
accomplishes is that from the employees
perspective you help eliminate two basic
problems one is the entitlement effect
which says gee I got these are you
giving all these options when I came I
don't get any more options so I've got
to do as as AOL One said to me rest and
vest if there's always more out there
there's always more to get second thing
that it does is very it's much more
motivating to people to go for targets
we love to play games yeah you can go up
to Reno and you can do this for four
hours and you you'll lose but it's
really fun because it's a game
if you go up to Reno I say give you a
fifty bucks do this for four hours win
or lose nobody would do it because it's
boring this is the same thing that most
jobs are this after a while but makes
them interesting as the game attached so
if you can say here's the game then you
have scoreboards and you keep sharing
these numbers and you make a big deal
about it it's very motivating to people
so that's a to me that seems like the
most sensible way to do it and some
companies do it that way many more than
used to when when we started sort of
preaching this message over a company
said you give everybody however much
ownership they're gonna get when they
start and now the shift is more to
parceling it out over time part and
increasingly based on performance
targets and I think that makes a lot of
sense shareholders like that too by the
way because if you're an investor in
these companies you can say okay I'm
willing to give up more if we grow more
and from the investor's standpoint one
of the interesting things is there's an
asymmetry and how they value current
costs versus future gains as you may
have seen all this work that Daniel
Kahneman has doing it but who's that a
name people know he's a behavioral
economist at Princeton won Nobel Prize
and he's done these kinds of experiments
we'll say I've got ten dollars and I'm
gonna give it to the two of you but you
have to decide how to split it so here's
the deal five and five great we'll each
take five how about this deal six and
four I don't know okay how about eight
and two no way I'm not kidding - and he
gets eight well that means neither of
you get anything but most people won't
take that deal similarly if you say to
people okay I'm gonna you've lost $500
double or nothing
see if you can get your $500 back most
people will take that bet you've won
$500 double or nothing even a thousand
or zero
most people won't these are exactly
comparable economic scenarios now
imagine you're an investor what behavior
does that lead to protect your losses be
much more concerned about your losses
than giving up potential gain of
neoclassical economists and traditional
investment models assume that that's
just total hokum but in fact that's the
way people behave and so if you say to
investors would you rather give up a
dollar and cash as compensation or the
potential that we've measured through a
black Scholes model that says this is
worth a dollar of potential future gains
they're much more likely to take the
dollar of future gains deal so if this
sort of that's our dynamic approach
works everybody it also eliminates the
lottery effect which is you happen to go
work for the company at the right time
so your options are worth a lot but then
the company did well and you got options
up here and then it didn't do so well so
your options are worthless and the guy
working next to you is doing exactly the
same job is really